[Applause]
host of The Today Show he was also on
that other show you know what happened
Billy Boy Kathy Griffin on last week I
feel like this is my month to
rehabilitate people who should who
should not have been made to go away
this country I'd like to get back to
normal as we know you were you know the
guy in the bus with the president when
he said those nasty things about
grabbing [ __ ] first let's just ask how
we you would have handled it differently
now that you look I can look back I
probably would have just changed the
topic I mean I spent a lot of time with
Trump back then because yeah I didn't
really set that you in trouble you were
just the ex I was the entertainment
correspondent for NBC and he was the
cash cow
he was the cash cow he was pulling 20
million viewers a week or something so
I'm with him two three times a week you
had to kiss his ass yeah I eat sort of I
mean you sort of meet them where they
are or you can interrupt him and then
you know how volatile he is right so
he'd be like I hate Billy Bush she's
done moving on Entertainment Tonight
only forget Billy Bush he's and then I
have to explain why I lost the right
Trump the big fish right so okay so and
I'm sure everybody says this to you but
it is weird that he kept his job and you
lost yours little irony yeah how has
that made you feel the last year and a
half yeah are you over it I'm sure there
was a period of bitterness yeah oh yeah
it's definitely it's in the beginning
you know it's it's it's chaos right it's
you got order in your life and then all
of a sudden in an instant you have chaos
right and you don't know what end is up
and there's paparazzi all over the place
and you're then you're wondering you're
gonna be okay am I done am i I don't
know and then you go into the the whole
thing but then you sort of come out
oddly enough the day the Trump walked
into the Oval Office was the day that I
walked into a self-help rich
in Northern California to sort of get
back on my feet it's called the Hoffman
process I go up there and I'm seven days
off the grid I'm like the guy from Ohio
there who knew too little you know no
phones no nothing and and that was the
beginning of just getting over it look I
mean if things happen to people all in
all my life
is pretty good I got right I got great
kids I got a I got a great family and
life is random bad bad things happen to
good people good things happen to bad
people
yeah it's why people like me or atheists
how about you did it make you lose your
faith bill I thought you'd like this I'm
donating the 850 dollars I get to appear
here to the church in Los Angeles just
gonna say I thought you external events
you can't control write a whole bunch
self-help work you can't control what
happens you can only control how you
react to it how you handle it
and it took me a while but then I said
wait a minute hold on things are pretty
good get back on your feet and I took my
daughter to Japan and she's 13 years old
obsessed with Japanese culture we went
there for ten days I got a trip planned
with my with my middle daughter I'm
doing a little time you know things like
that that it's just well you ever wonder
what happens to you if like everything
went away the big career the big show
HBO the whole thing what does it happen
oh it's hits last before my eyes about
few things about Donna cuz you obviously
do know him better than most why did
first of all um did he have a type like
you know like in the in the fire and
fury book Michael Wolfe says you know
like his whole life was based around
chasing women like Bill Clinton I mean I
saw him on camera here and there but I
did host you know for Miss USA pageants
and for universe pageants for NBC at the
time and you know he's yeah he's
definitely a you know he would come
backstage to all the reports you've
heard of you know running backstage and
reviewing the guard like you know kim
jung-han reviews
military he comes back with the with the
tie that's too long past the belt and
the overcoats and yeah but I think we
all we know about Donald Trump right we
know who the guy is well on this story
that I love that I think is so
indicative is when you called him on the
ratings once you said because the
Apprentice was like number 30 and he was
saying it's number one well he's been
saying number one forever right and
finally I'd had enough I said wait hold
it wait a minute you haven't been number
one for like five years of four years
whatever it is not in any category not
in any demo he goes well did you see
last Thursday
last Thursday 18 to 49 whatever the last
five minutes or whatever I said you know
no I don't know that's that
no I so he's like I told you and then
later after when the cameras are off
when the cameras are off he says he goes
Billy look look you just tell them and
they believe it that's it you just tell
them and they believe that's they just
do and I said that's okay so where we
are and so from that point forward X is
how natural it was number one we were
number two but the fact that he can do
that to America now and because that's
exactly what he does all the time he
just says it and they believe it yeah
people do he never said he was sorry to
you right I mean he never said he's
sorry the phone rang yeah well he didn't
do it I mean in fairness he didn't you
know and delete a tape but I didn't want
him to call I don't want to talk about
this I haven't spoken to him in four
years I have tears one more thing did
you actually give him the Tic Tac when
he asked for the time because I always
thought that your Tic Tacs right I
always thought the Tic Tac was sort of
like the like a Columbo episode that was
the little detail that that showed that
he wasn't this wasn't just locker room
talk he was really gonna do it across
why else do you need the Tic Tac know if
you're not gonna kiss somebody why Billy
give me attack there are few years ago I
kissed a lot of ass but that's where I
drew the line
no ticked at all so I did not give him
the title did not give him I draw the
line where to a found that out
no tic-tac okay so you did eight
pageants you said with them I just when
I was reading about that I just was then
let me ask this panel this to the idea
of pageants
it just seems in 2018 like something
we're like are we still doing that it
just seems very anachronistic at this
moment that hey come on out in the
beginning so yeah I walked away I sort
of had the same feeling like I don't
think I can do any more here I don't
want to tell women who are legitimately
trying to do pageants to get scholarship
money and I know it's a sad thing
many women do feel like they have to
trade on their sexuality to make it
ahead in the workplace and the the
scariest thing about the tape and how
women like me I think viewed it wasn't
the internet so just the interaction
between you and Donald Trump but was
your colleague coming in afterwards and
not knowing that everything that had
been said in the room before her and
it's affirms the suspicions we've always
had that our men in the workplace won't
respect us the same way and I think the
easiest honestly solution to that is for
when people are in a room where
everybody looks like you and somebody
says something racist or sexist to have
that social courage to thank me but
that's not okay
[Applause]
I'm calling it social courage for a
reason because that is more difficult
than joining a rally of 20,000 people
who think exactly like you and because
those are the those are the rooms where
that change really needs to happen and
that's something that every man can do
on behalf of your daughters your mothers
your friends and your sisters I have
three daughters and you know it hit home
when you realize well she's gonna be in
the workforce someday she's gonna be
going if she walks out of a room and
someone you know was talking about her
behind her back that'll upset